huyen del virus del hambre había a
través de las trochas y en las bermas de
las carreteras el cierre de las
fronteras por la pandemia de kobe 19 en
los países andinos no cesa el empeño de
miles de migrantes venezolanos que
buscan una vida digna para ellos y sus
familias para nadie un secreto para
conseguir dinero en venezuela es muy
difícil este pues no toco ven y de
mochilero ya tengo muy 21 día mochila
ando y por trocha y pues nos toca pasar
un río camina monte con mucho riesgo y
hemos pasado hambre también ha sido
fuerte la cosa algunas que otras
personas nos ayudan otras nos tratan mal
nos ofenden nos insultan se cuentan por
miles los migrantes que cada mes siguen
caminando desde colombia hacia perú y
ecuador a través de peligrosos pasos
ilegales que las autoridades de estos
países no logran controlar muchas veces
gestionadas por mafias los venezolanos
se ven obligados a mendigar para poder
pagar entre los 5 y 10 dólares que les
exigen las mafias para cruzar las
fronteras una valiosa cantidad para los
que no tienen nada a la precaria
situación de estas personas que viajan
durante semanas se suma la cada vez
mayor militarización de las fronteras
en estos países tanto ecuador como perú
desplegaron más de 50 vehículos del
ejército y 1200 soldados para frenar el
paso de los migrantes
tenemos un despliegue tanto del lado
peruano como del lado ecuatoriano
también hemos observado tropa
ecuatoriana de los dos lados de la
frontera y creo que eso muestra que
tenemos estamos haciendo un esfuerzo
conjunto para garantizar que cualquier
paso de un lado a otro sea por la vía
legal y por la vía correcta los países
de américa latina están sumidos en la
lucha contra la segunda ola de contagios
por el virus siendo las restricciones a
la migración una de las principales
herramientas argumentando que los
migrantes suponen una amenaza sanitaria
por el coronavirus